my question is why weren't they criminal
cases and why were they civil oh
interesting because they just want money
well maybe also the chances of being
able to win a Criminal suit is way
harder
but he should be going to jail if he was
a he
[Music]
all right Joe's going to be really happy
about this news uh Michael Jackson's
company is officially going to trial for
the role that it played
allegedly during the 1980s abuse of Wade
Robinson and James six Chuck whoa suck
on that Joe because remember at first it
got struck down no it's it's like saying
like in your face
so many big words so remember
how they were like suing and they they
can't sue actual Michael Jackson but
they can sue the estate for not doing
anything to help them and for assisting
in the molestation that it occurred what
but now it's a now it's a reverse suit
how how's it reverse it it literally
says it's not no wait what is it how is
it now the state's saying in your face
the state the estate I'm confused dude
what is happening
that's not what's happening they're
going after the Michael Jackson estate
yeah no the um yeah because at first
they were like the uh the court said
there's no way to prove that like uh or
they said that uh an employee is not
responsible for the actions of you know
the boss yeah because they can't disobey
the boss if the boss is like hey nobody
come in this room in the next two hours
they have to just not do that yeah but
then now it's being said that uh the
court is finding that oh there are
instances where they did know that it
was happening but the estate did know
yeah because of like private comments
that were made so so if they prove that
then it's [__] done then it's done so
yeah
Joe what do you think it's not proven
innocent till proven guilty yeah dude
what you guys gonna cancel based on
allegations
I guess those I guess you guys are part
of the castle culture then
until they prove it you think this this
court case is going to be live on TV
I don't know I don't think so no I feel
like it won't if Michael was alive it
would be yeah yeah but we're gonna see
if he was a lot this would be on stage
do you know Wade personally I don't no I
mean I've met him once but Dante does
what's the uh I bet him yeah Hawk knows
him personally really because I think
like as one of the most empathetic
people in the world
I'm trying to figure out like why what's
the point of pursuing if the
motherfucker's dead I think it's it's
a money hungry man let's say that it's
money but but if it's not money it's the
fact that this would be the one time
that at least legally it would be
confirmed that it really happened
but what's the point of that you know
but then they get money for that come on
dude but the point is that if let's say
that you let's just greedy well you
think it's just I'm just trying to boil
it down to like because I don't
understand all this [__] so I'm just
like trying to understand like okay at
the human level what is this
[__] trying to do imagine you
got well I know because you understand
trauma so well
I'll have to explain this for too long
um but imagine you were molested by your
hero basically and that has [__] you
up your entire life and who knows what's
happening with you behind closed doors
like sexual relationships all kinds of
[__] your whole life stemming back for
as long as you can remember from your
[__] hero [__] you the Dave
Chappelle butt [__] me since I was
five exactly would you be bummed up and
the world against you thinking that
everyone's calling you a liar yeah and
that you just want money you're like
Bart you're [__] you're you're trying
to rob Dave Chappelle that's because he
wasn't just you know your hero he's a
bunch of other people in that in that
genres hero too and all these other
dancers coming up you're like Michael
Jackson is my biggest inspiration [__]
[__] you for [__] on my hero and
then so like no matter where you go
you're like ostracized and [__] but no
that's probably not gonna cause much
trauma
two weeks no now with a set of Flapjacks
in front of you I think what would make
me feel
full wouldn't be the money part because
my my butthole already got [__] I go
to his go to his grave and [__] [__]
and piss on like every day or something
do you think that'd be more that's his
value so you're saying that legally that
he should be able to love the piss and
[__] on Michael's grave yeah maybe
that's what they're fighting for yeah
maybe that's in the closet Different
Strokes for different folks dude I mean
I think that's that's what that you are
right I think that's what it is he just
wants it to be acknowledged and then
also get money
which is really hard to not like you
know I I could see that if the whole
world thought you're the scumbag for
creating these fake stories and you just
want to like exactly set the record
straight I understand and then it's
confirmed and you get 30 million dollars
or whatever one thing one thing that I
do know is that it's not characteristic
at least for him to be this guy that's
just trying to get money because he's
successful exactly like he's got his own
like career he's arguably one of the
most successful that he lives in Hawaii
too oh really he's a Hawaii guy dude
well I'll tell him stop please he's not
a litigious person he doesn't go around
like suing everybody for [__] so it's
that's that's kind of what he does have
a lot of credibility so it kind of gives
him a lot of validity on what he's doing
like he's not he gives him credibility
yeah like if somebody's gonna be
accusing Michael of that I mean at all
of these different kids have at
different times yeah this would be the
one guy that probably doesn't need to do
it and it would probably have more
damage which it has on his reputation
yeah I wonder why the legal system's So
based on money what if you send
Michael's kids to be his servants for
like two decades
it's cool because then it's time
yeah he's like why are people so
materialistic waits like blankets
it come here blanket I think it could be
his landscaper for like two two years or
something doing chores something
yesterday literally still call this kid
[__] blanket for sure you
they call him blank man yeah they that
would be a way better outcome slavery
indentured servitude I think that's cool
that used to be a actual thing back in
good old Sumeria
to totalitarian dictatorships
didn't even have zip codes back then huh
did you like did you I think
who who here actually watched uh they
had male in ZIP codes well here actually
watched leaving Neverland I watched all
of it
you were just like this
bro Joe's yelling the TV the whole time
he's like he's a [__] liar
throwing [__] like it's the finals
I even had a raging raging argument with
Dante and I'm like
no way he goes I know way way would a
lie and I'm all like he looked like a
lie on the documentary
hey
Dante's a weight supporter yeah but then
he goes It's hard man because he goes
like yeah because he said that one day
um he would he went to go see Michael
and then Michael was like too busy and
then but who came out was bubbles so he
got to hug bubbles or whatever and then
so I was like you're just jealous
because you didn't get to see him
personally and then he gave you [__]
bubbles instead he's making that [__] up
I'll say that right now he went to see
Michael and said Michael's monkey
bubbles came out and gave him a hug yeah
get the [__] out of here dude get the
[__] out of here
that's a story he told that you guys
actually got mad at each other now we're
just talking about how I was like so
we're like oh you know he goes man I
know way man he goes like you guys said
he's a he's a good dude like Wade's just
like it's just so weird for him to like
come out of nowhere and say this like he
never said anything about whatever no I
think during that time Hook was really
big too and you know how uh Michael
Jackson loved Peter Pan and all that and
then so Rufio was like a big thing so I
think like Dante didn't see him in that
light he didn't know and he didn't know
that
like everybody's dream was probably to
be in Wade's shoes because of uh the the
whole like a mentorship kind of thing
like it's like the closest in the
Friendship everyone wanted it right but
I remained skeptical because of previous
accusations
were basically thrown out they were
settled though
[Laughter]
my question is why weren't they criminal
cases and why were they civil oh
interesting because they just want money
well maybe also the chances of being
able to win a Criminal suit is way
harder
but he should be going to jail if he was
a hee here
we know what that is yeah honor Michael
Jackson is on the Epstein list or on his
any of his flight manifests nah because
Epstein has girls dude she's probably on
his list yeah
that's true Michael was big yeah he had
his own list he was on pjs he didn't
yeah so like some of the records they
have are like from security Personnel on
the estate like making comments about
like
um Michael's preferences for like what
he likes nowhere namely not being women
and more along the lines of specifically
white little butts
I swear to god dude I'm thinking I'm
like okay so far it's pretty reasonable
and then I'm like oh Jesus all right I'm
not even like little white butts though
little white bugs
yeah okay that's the actual do you think
do you think okay one of his biggest
Defenders sounds like
I know I like white little books
do you think
okay one of his biggest Defenders and
supporters is Macaulay Culkin right yeah
yeah so do you think he has a little
white butt back yeah but do you think
Michael didn't think he was fine no I
think he was too big bro
I agree so he likes little little no not
like that I mean like he he was the
biggest star at that time the biggest
Kickstart If he if he did anything to
him and McCully blew the whistle he
couldn't get away with that [__]
everyone believes him yeah everyone's
gonna believe uh Macaulay he's the one
fighting robbers bro in his house so
Michael you're saying is a groupie lover
I'm saying dude if he maybe if he was I
think it's easier remember Fuller yeah
from Home Alone
gets smashed look what you did you
little jerk yeah yeah yeah yeah if he
was if he was if he was trying to [__]
Fuller instead Fuller has less
credibility with the public no one I
forgot his that was his name ranking the
kids what about buzz buzz no he wasn't
just
in terms of Wade Robson most people
within one or two degrees from him could
like they would say they believe him
just because it's like he his rep and
then most of the people that are like oh
like that's a [__] liar it's like
that that's just they just love Michael
it's like that's cool I always think
that it takes a significant pair of
balls to say to people like out in
public like hey I got railed in the ass
by Michael Jackson for years like what
is that benefit and to keep that story
up too yeah that's true yeah like hey
dude I was getting like [__] taken
all all day by Michael Jackson like that
makes him look like to people right to
people we all know those people from
school and [__] like oh well you're gay
or whatever all that stuff forever now
yeah that's true I don't know that's not
that fun yeah but you know what canceled
it out does he had sex with Britney
Spears and then he Justin Timberlake
wrote about him really he's crying me a
river dude that's him Wade robson's
Grammy River thought that was Brittany
well it was about them how about them
together yeah oh [__] really yeah it was
about her being a cheating ass with Wade
no way over JT huh yep so that's the
straightest thing I've ever heard dude
well does that does that uh like so
Michael Jackson lower The credibility no
means Michael Jackson he was [__]
Primo Brittany and you're saying that's
the straightest thing you've ever heard
Barry so you admit that Primo Brittany
was [__] hot will you finally admit
no Jessica says it's way hotter son of a
[__] I could never get him on this it's
so close we almost had him right he was
cornered I'm pretty sure that the
verdict that Wade's hoping for is not uh
so you're not gay
so what's this about you sleeping with
Britney Spears that's what the defense
says the defense could have so much fun
with that I don't think if he was ever
ashamed or afraid of being called Gay
because he's chosen the life of dance
and dancers get called Gay all the time
that's so true
so that's already step one I call
dancers gay all the time too exactly
he's a
we all do collectively right
so what's coming out and saying that you
actually
dig gay things
and that's not that's not gay if you've
already been called Gay
wait what just to be clear what
percentage of you
is in support of Michael in his case
101.
I was about to say a thousand
files dude oh okay the files well you
see you guys are biased you know why
because you have we're biased
so these two are biased because they
personally know the way I don't what
about me dude but you're a weight
supporter you guys you you guys are
anti-jewers so you're just gonna go
against whatever I say that's true but
you guys we made it back
you guys yes I'm predisposed to to have
uh empathy for rape victims
where does Bart stand in all this is my
question mine is
recently we've been finding out how
how many Hollywood mcnasties there are
um
especially like the more and more Elite
you go it's just more Michael was
protecting all of the kids
there's like more Cosby [__] people off
the streets there's constantly more [__]
coming out so originally I was like a
Michael supporter because from the video
you ever see the video of Michael
Jackson he's like in the limb owners
he's a girl's titties yeah yeah like
that one makes him look [__] straight
oh look at him
and then um so I was like oh that's for
sure he doesn't like kids
that's good evidence it's compelling and
but he was with Oprah but then just
hearing all the crazy [__] that's been
coming out and like just how much like
uh the secret like circle of
kid people these days I'm like I don't
know Manny you guys late to the game
though because he knows this he's been
protecting all of them yeah with his
power and what did he out the
perpetrators well he's scared too
because he's a little kid but you know
Corey Corey Feldman yeah he confined it
into Michael he has his story about how
he was a part of the he was being passed
around by all these Hollywood producers
and then he was gonna come out with the
video but something didn't happen you
know remember that and then um he has a
story about
like going to Michael and then Michael
that's and he was one of his Defenders
too saying like nah he was he was trying
to protect me after that and and uh
that's why I was like I don't know I
think there's only one true way to find
out and I don't know they don't use this
technique more often but you should
waterboard the Defenders yeah the
defense yeah you take Wayne Robinson you
waterboard him are you [__] lying for
30 minutes and if he go out after 30
minutes if he can say and he still says
yes then we just believe him right away
I think I think the funniest defense is
like if someone was a molester and your
defenses well he didn't molest every kid
like he denied some kids
[Music]